I was sad to hear this morning that Alan
Colmes passed away at age 66 a guy who
was a great friend to the show a great
friend to me actually he came to my
office in New York City known to many of
hannity and colmes fame I did not know
that he was ill but we did exchanged
some emails a few months ago great great
guy just such an overwhelmingly I don't
know just a genuinely nice guy liberal
radio host Fox News Radio and it's a big
big loss to the talk radio community i
know many mutual friends are also very
very upset about this and this was news
to me this morning announced through the
talkers magazine daily email and then
articles starting to trickle in about it
i first reached out to alan colmes
actually back in 2005 it was at the very
beginning of the david pakman show Pat
was like six months old at the time and
I said hey I want to grow i started this
community radio show i want to grow it
he wrote me back and said here's what i
would do we were in touch again in 2008
and again he wrote me back saying it's
great that you're growing here is what i
would do next shortly before I moved to
New York City he wrote to me as the show
was growing he noticed fit he said let's
get together when you're in town we went
to a coffee shop he talked to me for a
while he came to my tiny studio in New
York City would the guy who ran his
website hung out had me up to his studio
at Fox News had me on his show at fox
news I would email him whenever I had a
question about hey Alan there's an
advertiser a potential advertiser and
you know I'm just not sure about whether
it's a match ethically morally whatever
and he gave me advice that I think most
of you would absolutely respect when it
came to that and post-election we did
exchange a couple of emails just about
how crazy things were politically and
always always a really good guy to me
into the show so 66 years old passed
away this morning as I understand it
alan colmes nice person great
broadcaster truly sad and actually
remember when I was in graduate school
at Bentley University outside of Boston
I was still living in western
Massachusetts and I would have night
classes because I was in an evening
master's degree program and I'd be
driving home late
at the time Alan Colmes would be on at
least the local radio station I don't
remember what time he was live at this
point but he would his radio showed
beyond 10 p.m. to 1am or 10 p.m. to
midnight and I would listen to him he
was one of the one of the actual before
I completely got off of sort of
listening to radio at that time of day
he was one of the people I most listened
to and he will absolutely be missed in a
lot of people sharing a favorite of Alan
Colmes moments one that I liked was he
would get calls from just absolute
horrible horrible right-wing trolls and
he was really a master at managing them
on the air and it was I think it's
abundantly clear that I I saw his way of
dealing with some of these trolls as
effective and probably try to
incorporate some of that into how I deal
with trolls that call into the show so
he will be missed very very sad news for
the progressive radio community we've
got a great bonus show for you today we
will talk about david pakman.com poll
results we've got a maryland tattoo
parlor which covers up racist tattoos
for free and also surprisingly strong
views about a particular issue that
maybe isn't really a big issue to a lot
of people for the president of iceland
what is this issue how is he weighing in
we will discuss all of those stories and
more on the bonus show sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership the coupon
code I voted 17 it's available it gets
you a major major discount and by all
means use that code